where do you think babies come from they
sold at hospital from time they sell on
my hospitals isn't there in my changes I
mean the doctor to get the key and
welcome women get the kid that you want
how much did it cost $10 Patel is a baby
I was really big so they had to cut my
mom's stomach and they had to stitch it
up they come from up in heaven and
that's all I know is there another way
yeah just use the nice words Eric comes
where wait and the brightest of the
private spot usually at the marriage the
two couples kiss and then the man gives
the woman something to help the baby
hatch they like little sperms and um
they race and then the woman becomes
pregnant and really fat my to GTG okay
let's go to my ass dick oh I have a baby
a bit tubby let's go to the hospital
that have my baby yet go home now see
sighs let's go to the park
hey I'm just curious of what that was I
didn't know what that this whole that
was kissing okay so I kiss mommy okay
now they get a little bit it comes from
like big lazy like yeah hmm